I'm going to start today doing something
that maybe you will find surprising
which is I'm going to praise something
that the Trump administration did even
if indirectly the CDC is run by Donald
Trump's selection dr. Robert Redfield
the CDC under the guidance of Trump's
pick put together a fantastic document
about how to open the economy safely now
you might be wondering I don't know
David I saw that guidance that Trump
promoted it seems pretty stupid actually
it doesn't seem that good and you would
be right I'm talking about a document
that was suppressed by the Trump
administration and has only seen the
light of day because it's been leaked
this is a guide to reopening that's been
in the works for weeks
it contains really good specific
detailed guidance for different types of
businesses and organizations restaurants
verses churches verses childcare it's
detailed it's put together by
professionals and it was done by an
agency run by a Trump selected appointee
it's all fantastic except that the
documents were covered up by the Trump
administration to see that they never
actually see the light of day this is
almost as big a scandal as Trump's
bungling of the medical side they have
good guidance for how to reopen the
economy this is what we've been looking
for dr. Robert Redfield worked on this
for weeks at the CDC showed it to
doctors like dr. Burks and dr. pouchy
Redfield even approved it by email but
it was disappeared never to be seen it's
now been leaked to The Associated Press
by CDC staffers who did not have
permission to publish it
they knew the right way to reopen the
CDC put hundreds thousands of total
hours into this and they're just
ignoring it because the optics wouldn't
be good now by the way not I don't want
to get off track but even the guidelines
that the Trump administration did put
out about how to go to phase one almost
all of the states that have reopened
have not actually achieved the guideline
that supposedly you need to achieve to
go to phase one that's a different story
the document that the CDC put together
would have saved lives there are all
sorts of businesses that want guidance
for how to open correctly and the
guidance is different in a restaurant
than it is in a church so for example
they had a guide with advice for
restaurants and it includes lists of
exactly how bars should be cleaned pay
special attention to food contact
surfaces and how bathrooms at
restaurants and bars should be dealt
with it addresses the issue of physical
menus I've tweeted before the physical
menu is a cesspool of germs that should
be eliminated altogether it talks about
continuing to use disposable utensils
even for people who start to eat in the
restaurants this is really good stuff
tailored specifically for restaurants
but Trump just wants things wide open so
this guide was smothered and covered up
it has different guidance for churches
for example actually tailored to
churches for example everybody over age
2 should wear a mask at church period
Trump doesn't want that getting out
there put up signs all over the building
the church synagogue mosque whatever so
that people see the social distancing
guidelines wherever they look it
encourages video streaming or drive-in
services suspend a choir if your
community of faith has one because
people standing near each other singing
is a great way to spread droplet singing
spreads them more than talking these are
really good specific Rock
recommendations and it all went in the
trash now one other note which is the
cover-up
Trump's press secretary Kaley maca nanny
or McKenna knee said Friday that these
guidelines were not actually approved
but we have the emails to prove that
they are as early as April 10th dr.
Redfield of the CDC was sharing this
document with Trump's inner circle
includes Brooks and foul Chi
on April 24 he again emailed the same
documents to Burks and others and said
just look it over so that we can publish
it the CDC was good to go they had
approved it and they were just waiting
for the Trump administration to give
them the go-ahead with
never came and of course the Trump
administration insisted via multiple
emails you are not authorized to publish
this this is not okay to publish so this
is where we really are getting to kind
of the crux of what we're dealing with
right now
Trump handling this well from day one
would have saved lives I've talked about
what should have been done somewhere
between March 5th and March 10th it's
not this pretend game where I was never
gonna shut it down on January 29th when
we had no cases or almost no no we're
not saying that but we are talking about
March 5 a coordinated 50-state response
that would have saved a lot of people
now a lot of people on the right don't
seem to care very much about that but it
would have helped the economy as well it
would have helped have to prevent some
of the economic damage that we're now
seeing if we had a coordinated 60-day
50-state stay at home guideline starting
on March 5 on March 7 March 10 it would
be over by now we'd be past 60 days we
would be reopening potentially with the
guidance of the CDC document which was
thrown in the trash it's infuriating but
it's also tragic it's tragic
in terms of the life lost and in terms
of the economy and it all could have
been handled far differently without
having to go to these outrageous things
like no one shuts a country when you
have one case I agree but what about
when you have 221 cases like we did on
March 5th that's a different
conversation they don't want to have
that conversation let's talk now about
normalization one of the most important
and relevant concepts that we've talked
about during the current administration
is the realization that things that are
not normal are being normalized and
hyper normalized now some of this comes
from numbness humans adapt and things
become quote normal very quickly even
things we would not imagine would become
normal part of it is the Trump
administration working to normalize for
example corruption the way Trump insults
people the way Trump puts his family and
friends in prison
of power and privilege through his
presidency Trump's violations regularly
of the emoluments clause the weekly or
sometimes almost daily scandals with all
of it we have to work hard not to become
numb and desensitized to the insanity
but also the Trump administration wants
to make these things normal and the
truth is it works in part because humans
adapt incredibly well and very quickly
and outrageous situations become
normal-seeming or normal feeling any one
of trumps scandals from just the last
week alone would have been months of
coverage if Barack Obama were president
Trump's Justice Department saying hey
you know what we're not gonna prosecute
Michael Flynn who already pleaded guilty
by the way that would have been an
insane scandal during the Obama
administration
Trump's press secretary lying in an
unhinged way and cutting short briefings
holding 20-minute briefings that start
40 minutes late
that would have been three months on Fox
News about the lack of transparency and
descend the the constant dishonesty of
an administration Trump getting caught
as I told you 10 minutes ago it's basic
essentially throwing out or suppressing
the CDC's actual reopening guidelines
there are others any one of those would
have been a month-long scandal for
Barack Obama but they are blips for
Donald Trump but the real normalization
that is being planned is make the
coronavirus deaths normal and frame it
as we're back in business we're
reopening everything's okay we have
gotten past the peak and things are good
now and the Trump administration has
been hinting at this for a long time
with their entire we never shut down
because of the flu stuff the Cure can't
be worse than the disease were past the
peak we've handled it well things are
improving the plan has been for a while
now just don't talk about the virus
itself anymore talk about reopening talk
about businesses talk about CEOs talk
about how we have ventilators coming
after the bleach injection fiasco they
essentially stopped the normal press
briefings and replaced them with
propaganda events like a CEO roundtable
a day of prayer at the White
later today or maybe earlier today if
you're listening in the evening or
tomorrow
Trump is finally doing a press briefing
but it will be to make a testing related
announcement no doubt more testing
propaganda and now again they are
talking about car crash deaths cancer
deaths suicide all things that of course
are not highly contagious and are not
communicable it is coordinated you've
got Republican senators using it Fox
News recently put up an image that
compares heart disease and cancer deaths
to those from coronavirus and meanwhile
the deaths keep climbing we've now
passed the 80,000 death mark remember
Trump was saying for a month or longer
we're gonna have 60,000 then when it was
clear we would have more he said we
could have 70 to 80 now he's talking
about ninety to a hundred most models
now are talking about a hundred and
thirty thousand during wave one so the
plan that now is the one being put in
place by this administration is just
pretend everything's fine they've failed
you look at other countries you look at
Italy Spain Germany France others their
curves actually make sense in the
context of dealing with the issue and
Trump has failed Trump has failed so
they are not going to talk about it they
will make it the status quo just like
listen people die in car accidents
people die of coronavirus could this
work it certainly can work for a while
the problem is that ignoring the virus
and the deaths leads to more of it
because people spread the disease
Trump's calculating that ignoring it and
inviting CEOs to the White House is
going to get them reelected in November
news channels presumably will continue
reporting the death numbers and Trump
can suppress it as much as he wants
eventually it's going to catch up with
him eventually as other countries open
their borders to countries that have
this under control but they keep their
borders close to the United States
Americans are going to realize I think
something will be wrong when Canadians
are allowed to fly to Germany and Brits
can fly to Japan but Americans aren't
allowed to fly out
where you would imagine that that will
eventually have an impact and by the way
we still aren't doing enough testing we
are now getting to 300,000 tests per day
it's taken more than two months to get
there we need to be at 500,000 a day as
a minimum on route to 1 million a day or
2 mil we are just now approaching
300,000 tests a day even the simpler
things they're not doing and so this is
the new strategy it's gonna be up to
this up to us to decide whether we fall
for it whether whether we allow it
essentially because even though we know
that car crashes and coronavirus deaths
are not the same thing
takes a lot of work not to start to
become numb to many of these numbers and
of course everybody who is directly
affected by the virus is not going to
become numb to the numbers but a lot of
people are just in fantasy land they
don't know anyone who's died from the
virus and unfortunately for a lot of
these right-wingers until it affects
them personally it's just not real they
just don't care and it's gonna be up to
you and to me and to everybody else to
decide do we allow this to become the
norm or do we say this has been an
abject failure and this administration
must be removed 5 and a half months from
now that's how far away we are at this
point five and a half months let me know
what you predict I'm on Twitter at Deep
Ackman we'll take a quick break and be
back right after this the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 the david
pakman show at david pakman.com i want
to thank two people who recently signed
up for memberships at join pakman.com
Oleta Cox and Mary Rose bump not Trump
bump Mary Rose and ELISA thank you so
much for your support also a big thank
you to James Sobel James has been a
member for almost five years believe it
or not hard to imagine but it's true and
is today's longtime sustaining member of
the day grab a membership at join
pakman.com quick easy and you get the
daily bonus show produced just for our
members join pakman.com donald trump has
announced a new policy for the
coronavirus bailouts that is exactly the
type of so-called socialism note that I
use the word so-called that he promised
us multiple times now that this country
would never ever ever do Trump announced
it via Twitter of course saying that
quote starting early next week at my
order the United States will be
purchasing from our farmers ranchers and
specialty crop growers three billion
dollars worth of dairy meat and produce
for food lines and kitchens farmers to
family food box great news for all there
are so many things here to talk about
and to deal with so first of all yeah if
you have not heard about this that we
have food lines here in the United
States and they're growing and they're
huge all right the number of people
lining up at food banks waiting hours
outdoors in the heat waiting to get food
and also at certain nonprofits in other
organizations that are doing these food
boxes either for free or heavily
discounted this is what people like
Trump often say you would only see in
socialist or communist countries but
it's happening here it's happening here
in the United States it's been happening
but it's happening even more acutely
because of coronavirus that's number one
these are the bread lines that Don jr.
and others decried and announced we
would never have this in the United
States just months ago they said it it's
here it's been here but now it's here
even more strongly number two one could
argue that this is even more than just a
socialist idea Trump is coming up with
I'm not going to call it communist but
certainly we could be talking about
state socialism the government will
become the buyer from people who raise
food manufacturer raised grow food they
are going to be the buyer the government
and they are going to be doing that to
keep the company afloat and they're
going to redistribute those resources to
people who cannot afford them or who
don't have food to eat now remember
Trump has said many times we're never
going to be a socialist country here's
one example from the United Nations
today I repeat a message for the world
that I have delivered at home America
will never be a socialist country in the
last century socialism and communism
killed 100 million people now of course
I want to be really clear I'm not
telling you that this policy is
necessarily a bad idea given where we
are today obviously preventing it would
have been much smarter I am NOT here to
tell you that we are now a socialist
country I am also not a socialist what I
am Telling You is that this alpha' pull
yourself up by your bootstraps of
ideology very quickly changes when
things get tough and this is exactly the
critique of capitalism that a social
democrat like me has been making for
years we had in listen of course
inequality has been huge wages have been
relatively stagnant for decades by a
whole bunch of measures two months ago
we had a solid economy again by the
measures that are
we can argue whether it's thanks to
trump or not i think mostly it's not
thanks to trump but we had low
unemployment we had a high stock market
we had a appropriate inflation rate we
had high consumer confidence wages were
ticking up despite not not being
anything too dramatic yes of course too
much poverty we had hunger inequality I
get it
but compared to lots of times past and
many other countries things were doing
okay two months ago so the lesson is
look at how quickly we now have 15
percent unemployment potentially going
to 20% and how quickly we have explosive
food lines that are hours long and how
quickly we have the government buying
food from farmers to redistribute to
people who can't afford it this is not
about we should be a socialist country
it's just a reminder that the US has had
socialism when it's convenient for a
long time when there are calamities when
you need to bail out an industry with
companies that are too big to fail well
you'll apply socialism there need to
spread the costs out of fixing the
environmental damage done by industry
socialize the clean up capitalism for
the profit socialism for the cost if you
have a virus that you mishandled leading
to an even worse economic implosion than
we would otherwise have had well just
start buying food and giving it to
people in food lines so the solution
here is we should be dealing with the
fragility of the system in a proactive
way instead of reacting in what is a
completely impotent way that is the
problem and the point of social
democracy is you take capitalism but you
commit money to proactively insulating
the system from shocks and calamities
free market capitalism by its nature
doesn't do proactive it's just not in
there it's too expensive it's not
immediately beneficial true free-market
capitalism would not do the proactive
stuff that's why you need the regulatory
framework of social democracy and again
this is the type of stuff Trump said we
would never have here and he's doing it
and he's right to do it I that I want to
be clear it's the right it's one of the
right policies given what's going on the
logistical and crony istic elements of
it will of course be a disaster
always is the case for Trump but the
point is their principles evaporate when
they have a situation like this to deal
with this administration has made it
very clear they see vote-by-mail as an
existential threat to Donald Trump's
free election and to Republicans winning
in a whole bunch of different states and
Donald Trump now isn't even playing coy
about it he is talking about it he's
saying oh the fraud and vote-by-mail all
of that stuff but now Trump is going to
a new level
Trump is straight-up demanding that
California mail-in ballots not be
counted just throw them in the trash my
friends previously here is Trump
admitting that vote-by-mail would mean
many Republicans don't win remember this
it's just a common facts I mean they
have a majority in the house and
therefore you need their vote and they
want to get certain things I will tell
you this if you look at before and after
the things they had in there were crazy
they had things levels of voting that if
you ever agreed to it you'd never have a
Republican elected in this country again
they had things in there about you know
election days and what you do if the
more people that vote the worse you do
that means there's something wrong with
what you're offering if you win only by
holding down turnout and suppressing the
vote that's a platform that may not be
so good for people and more and more
states have decided in light of the
corona virus pandemic we've got to vote
by mail in 2020 at least November we're
going to be voting by mail California
just announced that Governor Gavin
Newsom by executive order said all
voters all voters can and should vote by
mail Trump doesn't want those votes
counted Trump announced via tweet that
quote so in California the Democrats who
fought like crazy to get all mail-in
only ballots and succeeded have just
opened a voting booth in the most
Democrat area in the state they are
trying to steal another election it's
all rigged out there these votes votes
must not count scam is democracy
functioning when the president says
votes shouldn't count if they are mailed
in or
cast in a specific precinct while we
have states like Oregon where elections
are by default vote by mail and remember
of course that Donald Trump himself
votes by mail in his new legal residents
of Florida which saves him a whole bunch
of money on taxes here was Trump
explaining that for him to vote by mail
is fine it's just not okay for other
people to do it so you were highly
critical a mail-in voting mailing your
mail in ballots for voting
I grew up in Florida's election last
month sure I could vote by mail further
because I'm allowed to
well that's called out-of-state you know
why I voted because I happened to be in
the White House and I won't be able to
go to Florida look well there's a big
difference between somebody that's
out-of-state and does a ballot and
everything sealed certified and
everything else you see what you have to
do with the certifications and you get
thousands and thousands of people
sitting in somebody's living room
signing ballots all over the place
no I think that mail-in voting is a
terrible thing I think if you vote you
should go and even the concept of early
voting is not the greatest because a lot
of things happen but it's okay but you
should go and you should vote I think
you should go and you should vote you
look at what they do where they grab
thousands of mail-in ballots and they
dump it don't adjust your monitor or
your speakers but that actually makes us
little sense as it sounds like you're
not miss hearing that Trump the
hypocrite once again and the things he's
talking about you know the fraud that
has happened with Mahlon stuff it's been
mostly Republicans fraudulently
collecting absentee ballots from people
and getting involved in funny business
his entire I did it because I'm allowed
to thing is completely circular
reasoning because what governor Newsom
has done is allowed people to vote by
mail by definition that means they are
allowed to vote by mail just like Trump
is allowed to vote by mail but of course
that's different in the world of Trump
now a few important notes about what
California is doing because it's great
and in fact every state should be doing
this going into November California is
not closing in person
they're discouraging it and they're
sending every registered voter an
absentee ballot they did say they're
going to keep some polling places open
and they've made a decision about
population distributions and where those
polling places should be but the sending
everyone a ballot is huge because in
some states they're insisting on the
normal normal protocol of will send you
an absentee ballot but you've got to
request it and there are usually state
laws or at least guidelines that say you
can't just send people absentee ballots
they have to request them clearly these
are extenuating circumstances and as I
said a couple of weeks ago governors can
deal with this exactly the way Gavin
Newsom is dealing with it which is by
saying via executive order this time I
am determining I am I am I have decided
given the circumstances we will send
everybody an absentee ballot even if
they don't request it very simple to get
around it hasn't happened didn't happen
in Ohio in advance of their mail-in
election but California is doing it it's
the right thing to do Trump is panicking
Republicans or panic panicking and we
know exactly why we'll have continued
coverage of this on the shows Instagram
page david pakman show on instagram you
can find clips and memes and polls and
all sorts of stuff while you are there
follow me on instagram at david pakman
major news in my urban garden my
cucumbers have sprouted ladies and
gentlemen and I will have continued
coverage from the frontlines of my
backyard garden a very very soon at
David a quick break too much more coming
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him welcome back to the
David Pakman show if you want to see the
epitome of management bioptics a term
that we've been discussing more and more
lately I have it for you today look no
further then CEOs told to remove their
masks before Mike Pence comes out to
meet with them imagine that people
around Mike Pence have tested positive
three people that we know of connected
to the White House have the virus more
are in quarantine
Pence's press secretary has the virus
Katie Miller she happens to be the wife
of Trump adviser Stephen Miller pens
should be in quarantine but is simply
not doing it he has a meeting over the
weekend with food industry CEOs they
show up wearing masks all five of them
they're doing the right thing someone
from Pence's staff comes out or someone
guided by pensa staff comes out and
tells them take off your masks before
the vice president comes out here we
actually have video of this you don't
even have to wonder how it went down
we're playing the video for our TV
audience you actually see someone come
out all of the CEOs are wearing masks
she goes up to the CEOs you see her say
something and she actually mimics the
motion of mask removal and they all do
it by the way notice how she's not
wearing a mask
she gets right up in the faces of these
five CEOs this is actually close enough
to spread the virus there is no
explanation for this other than image
and optics this was hours after Pence's
own press secretary tested positive for
corona virus and the Trump
administration has turned the mask into
a political element rather than
use my phrase here it's a political
element rather than L an element of
medical for lack of a better term now i
okay that's sort of a joke but this is
merely a public health item and it is
now being used politically if people all
around tents are wearing masks and Mike
Pence is not it could make Mike Pence
look bad but it also makes it seem like
it's unsafe out there and people have to
be worried about getting the virus which
they do and that is why people are not
allowed to be masked up around Mike
Pence
during this roundtable and it's all
about pretending everything's normal
it's about being economic warriors for
the stock market
Trump is increasingly using that term
economic warriors before people were
warriors for staying home now they're
warriors for not staying home it's
completely Orwellian Cayley Mackin Annie
was asked about it at a recent press
briefing and reporters were confused
because at first it was I thought I
thought people were staying home and
that was that was the war we were
fighting but now it's people are
warriors by no longer staying home and
just getting out there in Keighley
Mackin and he said that's right they're
all warriors when they were staying home
they were warriors now being out there
warriors and as usual these things
become vicious circles and
self-fulfilling prophecies because the
CDC recommended first responders wear
masks starting in very early April now
they didn't have them available police
departments fire departments etc needed
to find the masks but that was the
recommendation starting on April 3rd
that was five weeks ago imagine how much
better off we would be and how much
better off the economy would be this is
a point I keep making if on April 3rd
everybody started wearing masks if on
March fifth or seventh or tenth Donald
Trump said hey fifty governors let's do
stay at home thirty days you probably
end up having to extend it fifteen or
thirty more that would be over by now we
would be done with that Trump just
pretending that everything is fine it
also won't work for the country tons of
people are going to die but this
make-believe play pretend stuff that the
Trump administration is doing about
business as usual
can work for a few weeks but if the
numbers don't improve it's going to
implode we have five and a half months
left before we will get the opportunity
to remove every last one of these people
and we have to not allow a lot of the
stuff we've talked about today all needs
to happen we can't allow this stuff to
become normal we can't become numb to it
the hyper normalization happens
naturally to some degree humans just
adapt to what's going on if you're used
to seeing 1500 to 2500 people a day die
of coronavirus if it happens for long
enough and most people's lives remember
we're a country of 331 million most
people's lives seems sort of stable it's
very easy for that to become normal much
the same way the continued insistence or
sort of make-believe is essentially what
it is about everything's fine the
economy is opening here's a list of
states opening testing is great it's all
great that does work and we need to
fight really hard to make sure that we
don't fall for it I once again cannot
believe that we have to do this again
but Donald Trump still doesn't
understand how this virus or viruses in
general spread
he doesn't understand contagion he
doesn't understand communal communicable
disease I don't know if you've heard
this but the White House is increasingly
overrun with coronavirus infections
Trump is reportedly furious people are
having to quarantine one of Mike Pence's
staffers his press secretary Katie
Miller she happens to be the wife of
Trump adviser Stephen Miller a sick sick
guy more nepotism anywhere you look you
look under a rock you look behind a
curtain at the White House it's a
nepotism
she has tested positive for coronavirus
one of trumps valets these are Navy
people who are essentially personal
assistants to the president they handle
his meals and that type of thing one of
trumps valets has tested positive for
coronavirus Ivanka Trump's assistant has
the coronavirus y-you know she even has
any role in what's going on at the White
House is another question but she does
and her assistant has tested positive
dr. Anthony foul he is now in a modified
self quarantine along with dr. Redfield
of the CDC because they were exposed to
people who tested positive and Donald
Trump doesn't get it
how could Katie Miller have the virus
she was previously tested and she was
negative she was tested again and she
was negative now all of a sudden she
tests positive how does that work it
makes no sense to Donald Trump look at
this tragic video this is maybe the
dumbest thing that Donald Trump has said
in his presidency maybe I mean it's up
there it's in the top ten certainly take
a look well I don't know much about it
does anybody want to talk about it it
she's a wonderful young woman Katie she
tested very good for a long period of
time and then all of a sudden today she
tested positive she hasn't come into
contact with me spend some time with the
vice president it's I believe the press
person right say press person so she
tested positive out of the blue she
tested very good for a long period of
time then all of a sudden she tested
positive today I guess for some reason
she tested positive out of the blue
that's how it works at some point
everyone on earth was negative for
coronavirus at some point out of the
blue I guess to use Trump's phrase
people started testing positive who
previously would have tested negative if
they had been given a test guys he still
doesn't understand it he still doesn't
get it he's visibly confused by an even
more catastrophic is that Trump then
uses this as a justification to say
tests aren't that important someone can
test negative and then test positive
tests don't really matter that much
that's Trump's conclusion from all of
this take a look this is why the whole
concept of tests aren't necessarily
great the tests are perfect but
something can happen between a test
where it's good and then something
happens and all of a sudden she was
tested very recently and tested negative
and then today I guess for some reason
she tested positive so mike knows about
it and mike has done what he has to do
something can happen
between tests yeah it's called catching
the virus from someone else that's how a
virus works he actually says people test
negative and then they test positive
this is why I'm saying testing isn't
that important no that's why testing is
important and huge amounts of testing
are necessary levels of testing that we
are nowhere close to there is no worse
person to be dealing with this crisis
there is no worse or more incompetent
administration to have in power during a
global pandemic than this administration
we're trying to scale up testing we're
trying to evaluate reopening strategies
we're trying to explore the connection
between you know vitamin D and the virus
heat and humidity and the viral the
stuff Trump wonders aloud about bleach
injections and still doesn't understand
how a virus works when he says I don't
get it she was negative then she's
positive it's almost like he sees
coronavirus as a hereditary thing listen
she tested for having type A blood for
years all of a sudden she tests for type
B blood it's really weird how could that
change right that's not what this is she
was born Asian and now she tested black
that's really weird I thought people's
race day no this is a virus this is how
it works this is how people catch it and
this is at this point I think it was
Bill Maher who said on his Friday
program lethal incompetence lethal
incompetence that's what we're dealing
with and my biggest fear and I you know
when we talk about 2020 I try to keep it
to just the facts
Fighting's better on climate Biden's
better on judges Biden's better on taxes
Biden's better on healthcare Biden's
better on Capitol get right just we've
got it we've got an option these are the
two options we've got to choose
everybody's got a vote but I do fear
that the guy's gonna get reelected I
know that the polls are looking pretty
good for Biden this guy has figured out
a way you know he lost the pop
by three million and seventy thousand
votes in three states combined with who
knows how many other x factors that
we've talked about suppression Russia
etc etc Comey coming out and talking
about Hillary unnecessarily a second
time any one of those things could have
pushed him over but seventy thousand
votes in three states he won the
electoral vote
I fear that once again he'll get lucky
and there will be a decline in the virus
just before wave two and it'll time
right out in early October with people
saying hey you know what we got past it
even though it took longer even though
more people died he got us past it and
they're gonna go out and vote for him
and I'm worried we're gonna have another
four years of this and it is lethal
incompetence as Bill Maher said let's
work really hard to make sure that
doesn't happen particularly as you see
what's going on with federal and Supreme
Court judges this is urgent and when it
happens over for years and the country
is still here we might feel like a it's
not that bad no it's very bad and the
death toll is going to be much higher in
the United States than it needed to be
the economy is going to suffer much
worse and far longer than it needed to
suffer thanks to this and we've got to
all keep our eye on the ball and not
forget that in five-and-a-half months we
have an opportunity to change who is in
charge we can change who will be in
charge for wave two and possibly wave
three of this and we've got to do that
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your Chemex or French
press or a David Pakman show t-shirt
it's all available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
david pakman.com slash gear
don't miss the bumper stickers to david
pakman.com forward slash gear the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
Donald Trump's world is crumbling around
him he doesn't understand anything he's
furious all the time he doesn't
understand how viruses work how vaccines
work how masks work how Lysol and bleach
and isopropyl alcohol work and he spent
his entire weekend tweeting everything
from retweeting his own tweets to
pushing qyn on conspiracy theories to
attacking Barack Obama and the media at
one point listen to these numbers Trump
sent 52 tweets and retweets in an hour
that is almost one tweet per minute
Trump sent more than 50 tweets over the
weekend about the Russia investigation
Trump sent over a hundred tweets in a
single day I am NOT going to subject you
to all of these the content is mostly
irrelevant for our understanding of how
hard this dude is failing but check out
some of these are completely out of
control man without common sense or
inhibitions retweeting endless
conspiratorial attacks on Barack Obama
and the FBI for the Russia probe we have
some of them on the screen the content
is mostly irrelevant these are the
rantings of a madman and that's how they
should be interpreted continuing about
one tweet per minute sometimes three or
four or even five tweets in a single
minute Trump even retweeting his own
tweets from hours earlier we can't
possibly go through hundreds of Donald
Trump's tweets nor would it make sense
to the content again is not really the
focus here but the gist of this so that
you understand the next wave of
propaganda the gist of what we saw over
the weekend is that Donald Trump is now
renewing his claim and his focus on the
entire Russia investigation being a
calculated illegal conspiracy involving
Barack Obama to end his presidency and
unfortunately and this is why as I spoke
about it in the last segment I fear that
Trump is somehow going to figure out a
way to get himself reelected this could
be the perfect distraction from the fact
that almost 81 thousand people as of
this morning have already died from
corona virus and that number continues
to climb last week Donald Trump's
Justice Department decided they're not
going to go forward with the prosecution
of Michael Flynn Donald Trump's
disgraced former national security
adviser understand that Flynn pleaded
guilty and the Justice Department has
decided in what is one of the most
overtly corrupt actions of the trump
presidency hey we aren't going to move
forward the case against him isn't that
strong he pleaded guilty so now they're
using this absolutely corrupt decision
by Trump's Attorney General William bar
to try to revitalize the case that the
entire Russia investigation was bogus
illegal it was Obama's illegal plan and
on and on and on Fox News regularly over
the weekend using the term bombshell so
we're gonna talk about a bunch of
different things here number one I'd
briefly on the Michael Flynn thing if
Donald Trump had pardoned Michael Flynn
it would have been another one of these
sick corrupt elements of Donald Trump's
cronyism and nepotism and everything he
said that he would root out that he
actually embodies but it would have been
less concerning then Trump's Attorney
General coming in and saying about a
case that was built up over years were
you achieved a guilty plea yeah we're
not gonna prosecute that anymore that's
a level of corruption involving the
Justice Department that is actually far
scarier than Trump simply pardoning his
friend or his guy and will have more
time to talk about that a few other
things that that we need to talk about
first of all a hundred and twenty five
tweets in one day fifty two tweets in an
hour people who work fast food people
who teach school people who work in
factories me everybody I know who has a
job none of them have time to tweet 52
times in an hour even people whose job
it is to tweet
typically don't tweet 52 times in an
hour this is not normal behavior it has
to be stopped and there's only one way
to stop it and you know it and I know it
and it's happening about five and a half
months from now
number two the Republican Senate must be
punished for this in November I know
that there's a lot of focus on Trump but
if it weren't for the Republican Senate
Trump would have already been removed or
at least could have been removed
remember that impeachment trial last
week I got a call about you know what's
more important than moving Trump or
defeating Republican senators in the
fall you get to vote in both you don't
have to pick I'm voting in the
presidential or I'm voting in the Senate
election it's in all of the above
situation Republicans must be punished
they aren't just complicit they're
actively involved there's a whole bunch
of Republican senators martha mcsalley
susan collins cory gardner you know
we've talked about the whole list of
them they could all be removed in
addition to removing Donald Trump and
then lastly we're in the midst of a
hundred year pandemic and Trump is
failing in his handling of that pandemic
and he tweeted a hundred more than a
hundred times in one day if anyone did
anything like this at work if a
firefighter was tweeting while a house
was burning down if an airline pilot was
tweeting during an emergency landing
anybody else would be fired from this
they would be removed from their job
depending on what the costs were of
their distraction they would be
criminally prosecuted and we need to
make sure that Trump is held accountable
in the only possible way that he's going
to be held accountable I believe part of
what might have set Trump off this
particular weekend is Barack Obama
lashing out at Trump about his handling
of coronavirus and that's what I want to
talk about next I already told you that
Donald Trump was extremely triggered
this weekend and absolutely lost it on
Twitter tweeting 52 times in an hour
tweeting a hundred and 25 times on
Sunday I mean just absolutely outrageous
unhinged conspiracy tweets and what I
like to call a j't trash it appears that
one of the triggering events for Donald
Trump this weekend was former President
Barack Obama accurately criticizing
Donald Trump for his failed essentially
fake coronavirus response which has not
even really been a response which I
think justifies calling it fake
the phrase that Barack Obama used for
Trump's handling of coronavirus was
quote an absolute chaotic disaster let's
check it out from the Obama call with
supporters where he said this it has
been an absolute chaotic disaster when
that mindset what's in it for me
and to heck with everybody else when
that mindset is operationalized in our
government I would actually go further
Barack Obama says that the Trump mindset
of what's in it for me has been
operationalized by our government in
terms of coronavirus it has been I don't
want to overuse the term but you know it
applies here
Trump's guiding principle of what's in
it for me and what's in it for my
reelection it has been weaponized by
this administration and it has killed
many people who did not need to die now
the reactions from Trump and Trump
asleep redic table first of all they're
doing this entire oh you know this is
this is the corsa nning of the discourse
presidents shouldn't criticize their
successors or the lamella this is a red
herring because notice that they don't
say presidents shouldn't criticize other
presidents because Trump regularly slams
Obama put pulls Obama into insane
conspiracy theories a Trump slams Bush
Trump slams Clinton so understand the
flaccid hypocrisy of this a former
president shouldn't criticize the
current president but Trump regularly
bashing former presidents is fine
they are predictably pathetic and so
pathetically predictable
number two the
right is reviving Obama conspiracies as
a result of this so be on the lookout
for those not only are they saying now
that Barack Obama was personally and
illegally involved in trying to destroy
Trump's presidency before it even got
started
Michael Flynn you know all this other
stuff Pizza I mean it's just it's crazy
what Obama is being pulled into that's
number one but number two there again
starting to try to rehabilitate things
from the Obama era like for example h1n1
and Ebola h1n1 is a different story
altogether it didn't have the political
implications of Ebola but remember that
with Ebola in 2014 there were two people
who died in the United States there were
two cases that were transmitted in the
United States there were four cases
these are four not 4,000 not 40,000 not
four million four cases were first
diagnosed in the United States
eleven cases total and two deaths Trump
himself was calling for Obama's removal
in 2014 and we knew it was all politics
do you remember how we knew that the
2014 Ebola outbreak was all politics to
attack Obama well because the day after
the 2014 midterm election we essentially
never heard about Ebola again leading up
to it you had I remember Rand Paul was
unhinged Obama he'd failing on Ebola we
had two deaths doesn't make them not
tragic but we had two deaths we are at
eighty one thousand deaths and Trump is
making the argument that the cupboards
were bare from the Obama administration
that it's China's fault any shortages of
PPE are because of governor's
everybody's fault other than his own
when he said when you're president the
buck stops with you when it was Barack
Obama they're at that again okay talking
about Ebola and then we get to our third
issue just look at how painfully
unstable Donald Trump is I was thinking
of how to say it in other terms but
Trump has had months to deal with this
Obama accurately says it's been a
chaotic disaster and this sets Trump off
on was it 24 36 48 hours
of hundreds of tweets attacking Obama
acting like the exact chaotic mess that
Barack Obama describes while the cases
continue to pile up and the deaths
continue to pile up I was thinking last
night about an email I received someone
wrote to me and and said essentially
listen trump's basically doing as well
handling the virus as any random person
off of the street would do kind of
making the argument that like listen
trump's handling it poorly but it's
roughly what would happen if we voted in
any random person and said deal with
coronavirus I completely disagree Trump
is doing worse than the average person
Trump has very acute personality issues
that make him extra poorly suited at
dealing with this Trump believes he
knows more than everybody else
Trump focuses on attacking others and
shifting blame instead of fixing
problems my contention to you is if you
took a random person off the street
they'd probably do better than Trump
because they wouldn't bring the
delusions of grandeur they wouldn't
bring the narcissism and so they would
say hey let's find some experts and let
the experts do their thing and we would
all be better off
I believe Donald Trump is actually doing
a markedly worse job than a random
person off of the street would do if you
said what about a random doctor they
would absolutely handle it better than
Donald Trump has in total the average
person is likely to have better handled
coronavirus than did Donald Trump I'm
glad that Barack Obama spoke up you know
right away you you have the people who
are saying oh now we're we're
normalizing Barack Obama's presidency
with the drones no we're not we're just
saying though Obama recognizes what's
going on and he said it and it's
important for him to say it and I'm glad
that he did that's all that we are
saying let's go to your voicemails I
have two voicemails today both of which
have to do with Trump not wearing masks
of course our voicemail number is two
one nine two david p anytime you get a
hankering to call in feel free the
voicemail number works 24 hours a day he
certain time that's a joke let's go to
the first one let's take a listen
together
David this is Dave from California the
president doesn't get it he won't wear a
mask we need to explain it in language
he can get right
why don't reporters just tell them the
mask is like a condom sure it will help
you spread disease and help you not get
a disease maybe they need to dumb it
down to that level no no it's actually I
think that this next caller is spot-on
with her analysis I didn't even think
about this take a listen to this very
interesting yeah my opinion is I think
Donald Trump doesn't wear a mask because
it might sweat off some of that orange
stuff on his face right he took it off
he probably looked like an orangutan yep
that didn't occur to me but Trump's
spray tan would get all over the mask
imagine the embarrassment of taking the
mask off and it's all orange and some of
the orange is removed from his face that
actually maybe given what we know about
Trump one of the reasons of course it's
the management by optics he can't be
seen wearing a mask wearing the mask
would imply that there's a risk of
catching the virus out in the public
which of course there is as we see from
millions of global cases etc etc but I
like the idea we have a tremendous bonus
show for you today
Brazil's pind pandemic is just beginning
and we may end up finding someone who
actually is handling the corona virus
pandemic worse than Trump and that would
be the Brazilian President Jo bolson ro
who happens to be one of trumps buddies
Brazil is in really rough shape the
worst response in South America and the
one that Trump seems to most identify
with interestingly enough number two San
Francisco has confirmed that they are
giving limited quantities of drugs
recreational drugs to homeless people
living in hotels there are people
the right who are outraged there are
people who say this is harm reduction
and it makes sense we will talk about
that on the bonus show and then lastly
JetBlue the airline JetBlue wants to
salute frontline workers by a flyover
with low-flying planes planes over New
York City and New Yorkers were
understandably annoyed about it I have
stories about low-flying planes from
when I lived in New York City I will
tell them to you on the bonus show today
get the bonus show by becoming a member
at join pakman.com or becoming a patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
and in the meantime please make sure you
sign up for our sub stack newsletter you
can sign up at david pakman.com or at
david pakman.com it's the free daily
newsletter which will be morphing into a
daily written digest of the David Pakman
show
very exciting breathe free free sign up
on our website david pakman.com and I
will speak to you so soon on the bonus
show
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]